buongiorno
nella presentazione si diceva che nel
1945 il mondo è cambiato da quel giorno
siamo entrati in una nuova epoca
l'antropocene l'antropocene dove nasce
nasce dagli impatti che richiedono un
nuovo una nuova gestione del mondo una
gestione che possa che deve generare una
nuova coscienza collettiva
un mondo che sappia gestire la
complessità in un mondo dove soluzioni
precostituite e ideologicamente definite
non esistono più
un mondo dove i rischi degli anti alla
globalizzazione hanno avuto un impatto
sui diversi settori della nostra vita
quotidiana nella crema sono infatti
sulla dell'anzhi per caminita
organizzata sull'economia globale
il cambiamento climatico gli impatti
sociali come dici si diceva poc'anzi
l'alimentazione l'acqua e la migrazione
in questo quadro ci sono due realtà nel
nostro paese una e rennes a
un'associazione di giovani innovatori e
l'altra e clima lla una piccola startup
fondata nel 2003 e 14 da me è un altro
associa che hanno provato a lavorare su
quello che è il principio di resilienza
la residenza cos'è la presenza può
essere anche un cocktail presenza e un
cocktail che ha inventato giacomo
diamante è un bar tender che però cerca
di muovere la direzione in maniera
diversa un rapporto diverso tra quello
che è laico visto sempre come un
problema è la storia che c'è dietro e le
imprese che hanno creato anche rispetto
ai territori alle spezie che servono per
generali la residenza però è anche
esperienze complessiva l'esperienza il
caos ed è il caos che vediamo
rappresentato qui in una bellissima tesi
di giulia gaido la scuola politecnica di
design di torino la residenza richiede
delle caratteristiche richiede di
collaborare richiede di condividere
richiede di partecipare richiede un
capitale sociale che sia forte ed
evidente che sia valorizzato richiede
soprattutto una cosa che oggi manca nel
nostro paese ma si sta riacquistando la
fiducia la fiducia in quello che nel
prossimo la fiducia in quello che alle
istituzioni e ma anche un'altra cosa
serve che oggi
siamo siamo i feedback e sapersi dire
anche ogni tanto abbiamo fallito dire
che fallire non è un problema a fallire
è un'opportunità perché è un modo di
ripartire in questo abbiamo delle
esperienze in giro per l'italia che ci
raccontano quello che è la resilienza la
resilienza e quello che è stato fatto da
un gruppo di ragazzi a salerno con la
cooperativa terra di resilienza le
cooperative terre di resilienza sono un
ritornare alla terra da chi è andato via
da milano è tornato a salerno nelle
campagne di salerno per ritornare a
valorizzare quello che non una risorsa
era quello che raccontava maura nella
sua introduzione anche è il tornare bene
quindi ritornare nei propri luoghi che
con negli occhi diversi la cooperativa
atene resilienza non è solo un tornare
ma anche un riportare nell'agricoltura
quello che erano pratiche che sono
uscite negli ultimi 50 anni per la
globalizzazione quella globalizzazione
che ha generato il cambiamento climatico
ad esempio ma al tempo stesso la
cooperativa terre resilienti ha permesso
che sempre a salerno nella città venisse
creata o fondata da gennaro coppeta
attraverso la rete di slow food la
pizzeria resilienza la versione
resilienza nasce da un evento un evento
traumatico per gennaro nella sua
precedente esperienza di ristorazione
dove una notte per motivi alquanto
anomali da solo il suo stabile prende
fuoco
gennaro però che a 34 anni come me
decide di non mollare decidere di
ripartire decide di impartire una
maniera diversa e dice la sostenibilità
è una cosa per radical chic
oggi è una cosa che costa molto essere
sostenibili non è accessibile a tutti io
invece voglio portare la sostenibilità
nelle case di tutti si ricollega con le
cooperative terre resilienza si
collegano chi sono i produttori locali e
oggi genera da essere una pizzeria ne ha
create tre e ha riportato quel valore
sulla sul cibo che è un legame il cibo
con il territorio con la propria storia
era rifatto ripartendo dal proprio
territorio senza andare a cercare
al tempo stesso la resilienza
l'esperienza di residenza che ci sono
sempre nell'area della campania e quello
che avviene a barra si voglia
quando si dice che è vicino a scampia ma
è per identificare la tipologia di
quartiere che bar a barra è una zona
dove le comunità organizzata è entrato
profondamente nelle comunità soprattutto
dei giovani facendo rivedere quelle che
poteva essere una nuova speranza di vita
di ricchezza
però molti giovani sono rimasti senza
genitori e molti giovani oggi sono a
rischio che mi avete organizzata ea
barra il teatro itinerante di iqbal a
lavora con l'inclusione sociale di
questi ragazzi abbiamo fa attraverso gli
artisti di strada che in un anno al fine
dell'anno nel periodo di carnevale
realizzano il primo carnevale resiliente
questa iniziativa sia partita dal basso
oggi l'amministrazione comunale di
napoli l'ha fatta propria e la sta
diffondendo replicando negli altri
quartieri periferici della città di
napoli e questo è quello che è un'altra
esperienza di residenza dove
l'inclusione e l'innovazione sociale
passano attraverso le comunità e la
collaborazione tra le comunità e queste
sono tutte esperienze che vengono
replicate in giro per l'italia
un'altra esperienza di resilienza e le
scuole della resilienza è una scuola
promossa da rena è una scuola che l'anno
scorso è stata fatta al chilometro della
conoscenza a como chilometro della
conoscenza è un luogo di rigenerazione e
quelle che erano prima delle vecchie di
delle vecchie ville sul lungolago di
como oggi ritorno essere uno spazio di
espressione artistica di collaborazione
e all'interno della scuola
nella sua prima edizione l'anno scorso
abbiamo provato a portare quello che la
visione sistemica della resilienza
perché la residenza esclude di lavorare
il suo unico settore
se tu lavori sulla resilienza
prendendolo sulla un punto di vista
dell'ingegno
l'ira di urbanistica sbagli perché non
esiste rigenerazione urbana che non
richiede un infrastruttura e non
richiede una comunità e in quell'ottica
il chilometro della conoscenza per noi
era rappresentativo della diversità che
la resilienza comporta per la resilienza
però è anche visto che ieri sera abbiamo
avuto un evento finale con un rapper è
anche quello che amo sia fantomas è un
rapper di messina che canta la sua
resilienza e la residenza di una terra
la sicilia che secondo me è l'emblema
della residenza italiana un luogo dove
le difficoltà climatiche e territoriali
hanno sempre però spinto la popolazione
alla cittadinanza trovare nuove
soluzioni
in particolare questo non si è fatto ma
se ripensa anche la sua città messina
dopo quello che gli è venuto nel
milanese del 1900 quando quello che
sembravano gli tsunami che ci sembrano
molto lontani da noi e colpì la città
sta venne ricostruita la città oggi
continua a essere ricostruite rigenerate
con le esperienze delle esigenze di
comunità come quella è fatto in questi
giorni attraverso la street art ed è
espressione di un processo bottom up
anche qui avviato da un gruppo di
ragazzi come è stato fatto da
propositivo a macomer e questo e diventa
parte di un processo di amministrazione
questi sono esempi che vengono
moltiplicati e si diffondono sempre di
più sul territorio
al tempo stesso la resilienza però è
anche qualcosa che è istituzionalizzata
perché altrimenti se rimaniamo sempre
confinati nelle comunità senza rendere
istituzionali il processo è come dire
l'influenza non avviene per il comune di
bologna la resilienza e rispondere
all'impatto del cambiamento climatico
un clima che oggi qualcuno definisce le
bombe d'acqua piogge intense le bombe
d'acqua sono più un linguaggio dal
meteo.it a cui piace
nel vantaggio insomma dagli spazi
pubblicitari l'aja il cambiamento
climatico sono le ondate di calore sono
quello che sono successe
se voi vi chiedete cercati i dati dei
morti dell'anno scorso d'estate l'anno
scorso destato in europa abbiamo avuto
70.000 morti dovuti al caldo nel 2003
abbiamo avuto anche 77 mila morti e
fanno 150 mila morti dovute alle ondate
di calore
se pensate che nei dieci anni di guerra
in afghanistan ei morti sono stati 350
mila e paragonate due stagioni calde
rispetto dieci anni di guerra
forse possiamo cominciare a renderci
conto che il cambiamento climatico oggi
è una guerra non è più un problema
dobbiamo dare le risposte e il comune di
bologna in questo ha introdotto la
resilienza come principio guida della
nuova linea strategica dell'area
metropolitana per la rigenerazione
urbana nelle proprie infrastrutture oggi
c'è un vincolo forte tra la
rinaturalizzazione e il nuovo edificato
o meglio non c'è nuovo edificato ma ci
sono rigenerazione di quello che è
resistente al tempo stesso da bologna la
resilienza e anche quello che approccio
al comune di milano comune di milano che
insieme al comune di roma è una delle
cento città che fanno parte di un
network 300 città resilienti che si
promuove definire una piana e una
strategia di resilienza ma non solo ma
di istituire all'interno della propria
amministrazione un direttore della
resilienza e quindi rendere questo tema
questo nome che oggi troppo spesso viene
inflazionato basta sentire parlare aldo
serena alla fine di una partita della
juventus quando dice che la juventus e
resiliente io direi che forse il tema è
un po altro ma in questo la città di
milano cerca di ricollegare la periferia
e il centro urbano periferia che oggi è
scontro di quel disagio sociale di cui
si parlava anche prima ma è anche
esposizione di quelli che sono i rischi
ambientali lebran c finale le principali
inondazioni e alluvioni che hanno
colpito il comune di milano negli ultimi
anni sono nella zona periferica dove
oggi abbiamo anche maggior conflitto per
la città di milano quindi fare
resilienza urbana vuol dire riuscire a
valorizzare interventi economici
esistenti di rigenerazione attraverso
l'inclusione sociale e la protezione del
cambiamento climatico
perché la resilienza è dentro a ogni
aspetto della nostra vita nella sua
complessità
la resilienza il tempo stesso se ce la
facciamo è anche l'espressione di quello
che dove il luogo dove si svolgerà
quest'anno la seconda edizione della
squadra resilienza è il progetto
manifattura di rovereto è voluto
parlarvi del progetto manifattura di
rovereto perché è un po quello che c'è
in giro per l'italia in giro per
l'italia alieni in un video degli
spettacoli si diceva chiama commercio
sono molte industrie abbandonati a ci
sono molte caserme abbandonate progetto
manifattura è la manifattura tabacchi è
stata la prima industria italiana di
sole donne con l'asilo nido all'interno
e negli anni è stata dismessa la
provincia autonoma di trento l'acquisita
l'ha comprata e ha cominciato un
processo di rigenerazione di un vecchio
complesso dove prima si facevano
sigarette oggi si fa innovazione da
essere dal processo di incubazione si
entra in un mercato e quindi l'industria
l'impresa che diventa come dire parte
consolidato di un mercato e dal mercato
si passa alla manifattura 4.0 cioè
rendere quello che con la stampante 3d
che c'è anche in quell'angolo vendere
qualcosa che diventi poi ritorni a
essere produzione industriale
manifatturiero e questo lo si può fare a
rovereto come lo si può fare a macomer
perché gli spazi ci sono e i fondi sono
gli stessi si chiamano fondi di sviluppo
europeo fondi sociali e quindi con una
questione di volontà
in questo il progetto manifattura per
noi che ci occupiamo della scuola di
residenza è l'emblema è il simpson e
dell'integrazione tra la pubblica
amministrazione e il privato ma
soprattutto dove il privato non guarda
più solo al profitto ma guarda
all'innovazione sociale come uno degli
obiettivi prioritari del proprio agire
perché riducendo il profitto e
aumentando il bene della comunità che
poi non è niente di diverso da quello
che facevano le nostre industrie negli
anni cinquanta e ritornare ad essere un
territorio
con questo io volevo concludere dedicare
questo ted ai bambini di amatrice a
permettere perché non avremo più
permetterci che una scuola cada in quel
modo perché la resilienza deve essere la
resilienza della comunità e deve essere
la resilienza degli edifici quei bambini
hanno il diritto di tornare a correre la
sua scuola e di non vedersi mai più
crollare questa scuola la resilienza
credo che alla fin fine se ci pensate
siamo ognuno di noi e insieme possiamo
trasformare questo paese ritornare a
essere propositivi come i nostri nonni
ci hanno insegnato da quel 1945 in cui è
cominciata la troppo cena
grazie
[Applauso]